des gens qui venaient me dire que le
tatouage c'était une abomination
oui mais si ça me plaît à lui qu'est ce
que ça peut vous [ __ ] à vous êtes en
train de reproduire un animal sur le
bras est ce qu'on vous demande souvent
des animaux
oui les animaux sont assez fréquents
pouvait tout faire a ajouté
[Musique]
entrant en france
j'ai tenté de me déclarer tatoueur pour
voir si c'était possible parce que tout
le monde disait en france que le
tatouage était interdite
si jamais tu es déclaré apprentis
bourreau j'aurai le droit d'ouvrir une
boutique mais vous imaginez sur
l'enseigne auront leur parti aux
bourreaux des coeurs encore ça allait
[Musique]
je me suis déclaré dessinateur
intradermique et là ça a marché comme
une lettre à la poste
aux lisières de la butte montmartre
jadis paradis des artistes
il en est un unique en france qui a
choisi l'épiderme pour toi chaque soir
ils couvrent ainsi de motifs et de
symboles quelques bras ou quelques d'eau
[Musique]
quand je me suis rendu compte du travail
qu'il y avait à faire pour retourner
l'opinion publique
c'était monstrueux quand on pense aux
mots tatouage on imagine tout de suite
des gros durs avec des femmes nues sur
le bras ou sur le ventre et est ce que
est ce que c'est vrai ce que c'est ça
votre clientèle pas cela est bien révolu
si vous voulez ce type de clientèle
représente disons 30 % de la clientèle
maintenant dans le reste est pour vous
citer un exemple j'ai tatoué hier un
huissier de justice
[Musique]
mes tatouages aujourd'hui n'est plus du
tout le même que celui que j'ai connu
alors ils font quelque chose de
religieux une idole à totem et est
tatoué sur la peau de quelqu'un ça
représentait quelque chose maintenant
c'est devenu tellement beau que c'est
plus du décor intradermique que du
tatouage
[Musique]
ils m'ont avait perdu tatouage vrai que
j'ai vu tous ces gosses
il est formé pour la plupart excuses à
voir mais ça fait plaisir
si vous laisse à donner une vie on a le
sentiment d'avoir fait quelque chose
[Musique]